voilà on ouvre une page politique et
avant de recevoir dans quelques instants
mon invité Erwan legal responsable de la
section de mourpa du Parti radical
bonsoir bonsoir d'abord cette
information sur le député des Yvelines
Enry guenau Henry Guenot qui a annoncé
aujourd'hui dans un communiqué avoir
renoncé à bririguer la présidence de
l'UMP faute d'avoir pu recueillir le
nombre de parrainages suffisants il en
fallait 8000 je vous le rappelle il
regrette que seul deux candidats
puissent se présenter pour lui ce n'est
pas l'expression d'un choix
véritablement démocratique Henry Guo qui
espère que le nouveau président de l'UMP
sera ouvert à toutes les sensibilité de
cette famille politique et il va rédiger
avec d'autres personnalités politiques
une motion inspirée des idées du
gaulisme qui sera soumise au vote des
militants lors du congrès du mois de
novembre voilà c'était Henry Guenot
Hervan legal bonsoir vous êtes militant
du Parti radical vous étiez à l'UMP
avant la sission avec entre Parti
radical et et l'UMP comment vous
réagissez au propos de d'enri guénou
est-ce que vous aussi vous regrettez que
finalement il y a que deux candidats qui
puissent se présenter à la présidence de
l'UMP Jean-François copier et François
Fillon pour la démocratie c'est
effectivement un souci maintenant ça
reste un un problème propre à
l'UMP je leur laisse libre libre choix
de travailler vous suivrez ça quand même
tout monde de loin voilà de loin oui oui
écoutez je pense que on a forte àaire au
niveau du centre droit et ben oui
justement on va en parler de ce que vous
avez à faire le travail va s'annoncer
sérieux puisque hier votre président
Jean-Louis blot sur le le plateau de de
TF1 a annoncé la création de Ludi c'est
l'union des démocrates et indépendants
en gros c'est comment on rassemble les
partis du centre tous les partis du
centre tous les Parti du Centre alors
déjà j'ai envie de vous dire c'est
est-ce que c'est réalisable oui bien sûr
vous pas me dire le contraire mais on on
en a déjà entendu parler c'est ça que je
veux dire ça me semble cohérent d'avoir
un parti unique euh reliant tous les
parties de centre droit avec des
courants différents voilà c'est quelque
chose qui est qui est émergent et
maintenant qui est en place il faut
laisser le temps de cette for à cette
formation d'arriver et d'aboutir à des
actions pérenne voilà alors là pour
l'instant il y a 200 personnalités qui
ont déjà signé ce ce pacte fondateur oui
c'est satisfaisant c'est un bon début
ben écoutez c'est même remarquable moi
je trouve et par rapport au modem alors
écoutez le le modem berou a longtemps
porté les idées du du centrisme était
vraiment l'élément moteur du
centrismeouj écoutez le modem c'est
toujours très compliqué
euh pour pour l'histoire le modem est
quand même la continuité de l'UDF il y a
eu descissions à partir de depuis
quelques années certains sont partis ont
créé par exemple le nouveau
centre la position du MoDem je crois
qu'elle n'est pas très claire ils sont
les bienvenus en tous les cas oui vous
appelez quand même au rassemblement tous
les gens qui ont eu des convictions de
centre droit et qui n'ont pas ne sont
pas partis sur des courants de gauche
sont les bienvenus après il y a des
hommes et des femmes avec des idées
toutes les idées sont bonnes à prendre
en tout cas vous vous êtes sous
l'étiquette Parti radical vous allez
aller sous l'étiquette udi demain je
vous dis pour le moment il y a des
travaux des réflexions la semaine
prochaine je vais certainement être
convié à une réunion politique pour
reprendre des positions par rapport à ça
il y a un tête de un chef de fil je
j'écoute j'entends voilà je et votre
chef le chef de file dont vous parlez
c'est Jean-Louis Barlot est-ce que vous
trouvez pas que ça un peu brouillé le
message chez les électeurs quand il a
annoncé qu'il ne se présentait pas à la
présidentielle je ne pense pas je ne
pense pas après il a eu
euh il eu la sinérité de se retirer pour
laisser la place à un leadership qui et
vous l'z pas regrette vous en tant que
militant du parti radicale je pense qu'à
un moment la France avait besoin
réellement d'un homme comme Nicolas
Sarkozi et je trouve ça vraiment
honorable de se retirer à temps et de se
fédérer à un même homme qui était
Nicolas Sarkozi pour au moins gagner la
présidence fait àpo on se faére avec
Nicolas Sarkozi et aujourd'hui on crée
Ludi mais écoutez pas on se refère pas
avec l'UMP il y a Ludie qui a été
créé c'est quand même
une un ensemble de famillees avec des
courants vous savez l'UMP va avoir il y
a la présidence qui va arriver l'UMP va
avoir aussi des courants et des gens de
l'UMP vont certainement venir à Ludi
sans aucun souci alors ça c'est Ludi
c'est le National on va revenir sur
allez on va revenir sur MPa parce que
vous êtes là pour parler aussi de la
section surtout de la section de MPa
vous avez décidé de de relancer de
lancer la section de MPa du Parti
radical alors pourquoi MPa pourquoi MPa
parce qu'il manquait un vrai centre
droit à MPa voilà donc Pier leerinel va
être content écoutez le premier le
premier adjoint au maire comme je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure sur plan
national et du MoDem il fait partie de
la majorité de gauche donc voilà mais
quand il veut il me il me contacte
est-ce que vous l'avez contacté
justement pierre garinel au moment de
créer cette section du Parti radical
est-ce à moi de le contacter bah je sais
pas il est déjà en poste lui c'est pour
ça ah il est en poste au niveau du MoDem
pas du Parti radical mais àour pas oui
mais du MoDem comment vous allez vous
organiser alors àourpa vous allez
organiser des réunions publiques comment
vous allez vous faire connaîtreourpa
c'est il y a des déjà des choses de
réaliser enfin c'est-à-dire que il y a
des réunions publiques qui vont se faire
il y a des réunions d'appartements qui
se font il y a un blog et des réseaux
sociaux via le sur le Parti radical qui
sont en activité avec de l'information
quotidienne vous avez déjà des dates de
réunion publique ou de rencontesbut
déemb début décembre début décembre sur
les thématiques est-ce qu'il y a des
thématiques qui vous allez porter sur
morpors alors il y a des
thématiques il y a des thématiques
générales qui vont être axés sur mon
repas voilà donc la
sécurité la
l'environnement la santé les personnes
âgées toutes les choses qui font le
bassin de vie de mon pas ce seront
effectivement des des réunions publiques
animées par divers acteurs donc là il
faut rechercher aussi des gens
de de la
vie sociale la vie associative qui
souhait vous rassembler et est-ce que
dans l'idée du rassemblement évidemment
vous pensez aux élections municipales de
2014 écoutez c'est pas pour le moment me
dites pas que c'est trop tôt
c'est sans langue de bois franchement il
y a pas de langue de bois il il y a
quelque chose j'ai rellement des
convictions politiques et je pense que
pour se lancer dans une campagne
électorale il faut réellement comprendre
les dossier d'une commune moi je suis
vraiment partisan d'une politique saine
avec de la morale avec des dossiers
maîtrisés ça c'est très important pour
moi franchement est-ce que c'est le
moment de partir pas partir je nen sais
rien vous implantez sur
morpas voilà vous habitez morpas de
toute façon voil au niveau du Parti
radical vous vous créez votre votre
section et puis vous verrez peut-être
dans un an dans 6 mois faut pas se
lancer trop tard pour les municipales
quand même he oui puis écoutez je pense
que réellement je reparle des dossiers
il y a vraiment des dossiers de fond
qu'il faut traiter et comprendre après
avec diverses acteurs associatifs de la
vie politique voir ce que l'on fait il y
a le PLU là qui est en étudeinco aussi
il a terco il y a le cinéma il a y a
plein de choses il y a la piscine par
exemple qui génè un déficit de 700000 €
qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport à y a
de quoi fairez commencez avec les sujets
communaux les sujets loc y en a plein si
vous voulez on pe peut débattre
Etonti merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur ce plateau donc
pour parler de la séction du Parti
radical de morpa demain rapidement dans
le C sera la question de l'association
Laurette fugin qui fête ces 10 ans
également de la fête du cheval ou encore
de l'intérim bonne soirée et à
demain